hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay today's
[ __ ] made me use my even going the
right way maybe use more med kits I'm
gonna pay them back with bullets in the
face and crotch don't trust you don't
trust you Thanks hope you didn't break a
nail
my girlfriend's alive she's totally not
a hallucination where me come here
alright no more secrets
oh is that right something oh hello
no that don't turn around when there's a
power note right for the my face I
probably shouldn't be grabbing power
notes out of those important ones on fox
says oh oh whoa
back off whoa okay
what nothing twerk nothing stop doing an
electrical shock okay you're welcome
lady crazy computer lady who's stompy
stompy I need to hit his store
wasn't there a store down here somewhere
I guess I'll have to go back all right
going back up so that I can take the
long way back down encounter ten times
more the enemies who want some who you
know you you BAM
don't try it yeah then what was good for
them all right
store was around this corner yep there
it is
gimme gimme so much plasma energy if I I
probably could go through the whole game
with just the plasma pistol if that's if
they're gonna give me all that plasma
cutter if all they're gonna give me is
that Hamel I mean goodness gracious
Oh balls rounds yeah that's probably
more than I'd ever need whatever it
don't matter
yeah it's weird because you know if I
was just using a plasma cutter I
wouldn't have to buy ammo at all instead
of you know first assault rifle laughs
to buy ammo on every single time I hit a
store but I took on this challenge
because I can do it oh so awesome how
you also
how you know didn't think so
all right I don't know if it's gonna
dump me in the front of the back
well heard that I heard that whoa nope
it's not gonna get me here that
oh I thought those were actual people
for a second I don't know what that was
that whoa hello I saw that what is that
thing
well are you infecting bodies turn it
get out of here down here no no I have
another dog are you
No
so hard come any closer
huh give me the access codes to the
cargo bay oh processing why the hell
would I have coats the cargo don't lie
to me everyone lying to me yeah
Judah he's completely lost somebody call
security
yeah yes what are those things they
explode yep
they explode everything that's marked
yellow explodes small air cannon are
they gonna dump me in Xerox
ah did it just blow up randomly F that F
that house dug those stupid I'm stupid
[Music]
okie-dokie oh oh you don't look so good
buddy oh sorry
ah that better yeah they'd do anything
for you oh you lost your head there
sorry sorry about that pride for the
best you didn't look so good I see
something up I see someone coming all
right what do we got here yep no miss
Kraus
this looks safe whoa close that Oh what
the hell what's spinning those out dead
get dead oh those are the things that
throw stuff at me oh there's another one
get back no no take your tentacles right
off no no more no more give me give me
that mention I know I know choose the
tentacles stupid ah no gone give me some
ammo
who's there there omander everyone don't
come any closer I am armed and dangerous
and handsome tough manly and brave and
amazing and awesome okay
yep that's the slowest whatever the heck
this is for in the world why why I don't
know that my tools do the talk yeah you
betcha come on
what does whoa hey oh holy crap she's
alive but I can help you now well dirty
that's okay you clean you up real good
holy crap she's alive
that's weird
seems like totally unlikely oh hey I
think I could disable the lock from here
hold on
okay you do that uh holy crap
wow she's alive
now that's like I totally expected her
to be a hallucination whoa hey no stay
away from her
stay away don't you just feel lady over
here it's safer or maybe if I could get
over there no stop get away from us girl
oh yeah
give me that ammo not that give me that
animal no no I need to reload
give me your blade anymore nope not
going touch her don't touch it mine will
get her out of line ah no you're you're
gonna touch me
I don't get her hurry up Nicole doesn't
name right
I know I'll save you first not cared so
much that's another one I they're going
all over the place for no I know no no
no no
oh yeah sorry
all right there all right all right all
right oh you know it will just wait hey
where you going you can make it where'd
you go man just like stood there like a
lump didn't go anywhere and she just
runs away again a story can reach a safe
distance to begin transmitting I just
used yeah Hammond
well actually Hammonds prices a lot he
sounds too tough
but I'm starting to wonder you know
what's that real had to be there was so
many enemies but questionable
it is questionable her face was like
popping up on screens a hallucinogen
hallucinogenic hallucinogenic Li yeah
nope not all no just grow grow grow your
tempo go on
use my cutter for this probably what a
shitty get out here baby
point Wang ping pong miss miss miss yeah
I meant to miss I did it to even the
playing field
yeah oh no what am I gonna go for first
this one yeah run away baby nope nope
gone ah ah what where what happened
nope no I'm out of ammo I hate that gun
so those things are like mini babies
they're ugly yeah you almost got me
yeah uh-huh
thanks for the advice broham no my timer
went crazy there for a second sorry
about that
I gotta cut it here thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part
bye bye